he's the king feeling just eat the damn
child feelings I'm finally gonna eat the
kid
[Music]
the picture read the picture is the
picture read the picture it picture a
picture a picture
welcome everybody to eat la la youtube's
greatest show everybody the show where I
attribute means it's very unique it
different from all of my other shows
trust me trust me okay
no others it feels like I haven't done
this into one am i right with that
assumption either way let's check out
what you guys posted on the reddit the
pewdiepie submissions my man was going
for the handshake
this is so safe I've seen this heretic
can someone please can someone please
give that dog a handshake
can someone please do something wait
this has 33,000 uploads this is one of
the most uploaded ready post on the
purify submissions great great this
again eat the kids damn pictures really
you know what I'm not in reacting to
this I'm moving on I don't need this I
don't need this judgment by the way your
handwriting is terrible
moving on marzia big serve name the
wedding is off and Dara Felix eats the
kids picture I'm not about to marry a
coward
my own future way it's turned against me
is this where we finally fight this is
our first little fight just because I
don't need this child you're all mad at
me what if I don't eat him huh what are
you gonna do unsubscribe wait actually
tea service is coming please guys I need
you just for a little bit longer face
lampshade set out to eat my face and I
said until I ate a picture of him and I
said okay a hundred as a joke I didn't
think the mad line would do it
[Music]
your blood is not completely diluted
with the essence of beauty but first of
all I will not do any of the more of
these challenges okay
if I see you do one I will ignore it but
I will eat the kid at the end of this
video
just do it poops even you - even you -
LM a oh okay
if Peter pie it's a picture of that kid
will stop do monetizing his videos
I'm excited I never ate an Eton paper so
never eaten a child so we'll see how it
goes I'm excited pathetic if I ever make
a diss track burn some trash garbage and
legit make me well I'm about to do that
so you guys need to stop holding me
accountable for all the things I said to
be fair okay
everyone made diss tracks okay it was
the clickbait of last year you want to
use just make it stupid district and
they were all pretty terrible now I know
my district isn't the best one if
anything is falls on the lower end of
anything but it still floats above all
the most youtuber diss tracks that I've
seen and it was made completely
ironically I don't know how so many
people seem to miss that point I had
people go in like well you said you
didn't care about you series was good
but it's a joke it's a joke do I have to
explain every time I make a joke a blue
whale's vagina is so big and deep that
five to six men can easily lay down in
it making it the world's next biggest
[ __ ] after don't make me I will hurt
people are there gonna be any material
that doesn't involve this child I need
to know this right now okay that's
pretty cool
[Laughter]
the Chi one whoa I read a word in
Japanese nihongo - man
they're real right I'm surprised you
guys like the video I'm happily
surprised when me red shot it I kept
going I don't care like Elysee is
filming it's whatever I like we have a
new video that needs to go up tomorrow
it doesn't matter let's just film it and
then during the editing process I just
immediately turned into a psychopath and
when you need to cut all of this you
need to fix this this is exactly but
yeah I think it was worth it it was a
fun mean what if Felix doesn't eat the
kids picture he's a sociopath oh I feel
like a lot of people misunderstood the
video I don't have a personal problem
with Katie or Shane and I don't think
they made the video in any bad intention
I just thought it was a bad video that's
right I'm backtracking now backtracking
t-series needs only 2 million so no i'm
Nisha pity come back nothing is working
it's so obvious that t-series is gonna
take over no matter what so I might as
well Mimi I don't know why people find
it so weird I get people asking me
privately like so like what do you
actually think about it what do you
think what do you think stop asking me
questions but I'm gonna count down I'm a
sociopath and we live in uses dat you're
sociopaths breathe yes I just got cash
cut you always be monetized step 1
copyright the t-series district that can
easily be done put the song in every
video maybe in the endcard that's a good
idea
copy strike yourself oh my god we strike
yourself that grab it so blind
that's genius it was so obvious Obama I
just need to cover strike myself well as
silly as it sounds it's actually 100%
possible YouTube system is so easily
exploitable at this point you know there
are laws to protect reviews and
and references and you're allowed to
show them YouTube is responsible for
what is on their website so the easiest
action for them is just to delete or
give the revenue to the copyright claim
and it's a shame it makes it such a mess
sharing stuff is such it you know I
don't need to get an appreciating my
point
this is backtrack all the thing if I bid
this another claimant can still come in
and we would have to split it but at
least I would get half instead of
nothing for using like a two second clip
or whatever all the other lyrics in the
district but lasagna that's the real
intellectual line okay people don't
understand it if you think it's a stupid
line you don't get it also notice how I
kept going like this in the video that's
right I didn't realize how much I was
pointing until after where I review the
footage and once you see it you can't
unsee it this is some reason doing this
felt very natural for me at the time
okay
stop judging me upload the feelings
wheezing compilation yeah because he
never made it
[Music]
that's why pity pie should never shake I
need to shape like this distance is not
good maybe if I have it like that it's
all right thing whatever I got going now
it's not good
see Felix is not that hard that's the
best ISA Princeton I have seen in my
life I can't dis well finally real
recognizes real thank you thank you
having named baby eating the picture
waiting for the Sun right to make a
bunch of means are the kid for the
fifties Felix the child ate the Bexar
ate the kid sorry Felix is means locked
unlock automatically the kinsey oh my
god alright fine
can we get some man I need the right
music here we go
he's done this for 100 days
[Music]
I'm gonna swallow
such a health
and my garlic guy
[Applause]
you know all the sightings concerning me
and it's a different story
[Music]
under day
oh my god to die for dick
[Music]
alright no more of this stuff and no
more challenges if I see one I'm
ignoring it
okay it was a fun name for what it was
and face lime shade very well done good
job you did it congratulations I'm glad
no one died that's that's all I
appreciate right now thanks for watching
we added a t-shirt of me and review a
lot of people have been saying they want
a t-shirt version and it's cheaper so if
you want to get merch a little cheaper
version we have that now as well we also
have phone cases added how about that
that's great no one seems to buy this
one it's so cool I don't know why
alright well either way I appreciate all
the support on this it's doing really
well I'm very happy that you guys like
it and yeah just thanks for all the
support
IRA got to push I wish they had said it
has seven Diggs life that's probably six
things because this is a little hot
tomorrow I'll see you then
[Music]